ich habe mich heute sehr gewundert über
den großen klimagipfel in glasgow da
treffen sich ja die mächtigen dieser
welt die staats- und regierungschefs die
großen cios die beispielsweise bei
amazon gründer jeff bezos und wollen
darüber sprechen wie man das klima
retten kann und beim klima retten geht
es ja auch darum worauf wir normale
menschen verzichten sollen weniger auto
fahren weniger in den urlaub fliegen nun
wurde aber die große klimakonferenz zu
einer absoluten parade für privat
schätzt die daily mail die britische
zeitung daily mail hat sich heute
angeschaut wer alles in glasgow gelandet
es wurden über 50 privat jets gezählt
insgesamt werden über 400 privatjet
erwartet und da frage ich mich diese
leute diese privat parade soll uns raten
wie wir und sein leben verändern sollen
um das klima zu retten also wirklich das
ist der absolute gipfel der doppelmoral
und davon geht eigentlich nur ein
zeichen aus alles was die politik dort
berät das kann ein normaler mensch
einfach nicht ernst nehmen
ich glaube wir haben ja schon mit mit
sag ich mal dem gibt sie davor in rom
gesehen dass wir auch da wieder nicht
zur entscheidung dass wir einfach riesen
diskrepanz zwischen verursachen denn und
dann wieder ausbügeln haben in rom sind
wir zu keiner entscheidung gekommen was
wir denn jetzt tatsächlich neue
erreichen wollen in schottland haben wir
jetzt genau die gleiche thematik dass
sich da die westlichen staaten daran
aufreiben dass sie nicht mehr ausgeben
wollen um dem klimawandel
entgegenzuwirken
und die die staaten die auch viel von
dem co2 verursachen oder der co2 bilanz
viel dazu beitragen sagen wiederum wir
brauchen wir brauchen eine lösung und
wir müssen als kollektiv eine in einem
jahr eine umstellung da finden ich
glaube die die spitze des eisbergs sind
wirklich tatsächlich nur diese privat
jets aber das problem ist einfach eine
ganz ganz ich glaube wir können daran
erkennen dass die allermeisten staats
und regierungschefs das problem gar
nicht erkannt haben und nicht angenommen
haben sondern sie versuchen durch zu
kommen die denken an wahl und wiederwahl
und an wirtschaftliches wachstum und
andere fragen die sehr viel näher liegen
aber an die zukunft der menschheit und
des globus glauben die nicht wir haben
es ja schon gesehen wie boris johnson
diese konferenz eröffnet hat mit dem
verweis auf james bond man brauche einen
james bond da das sich bezogen auf einen
film wurde ihm sozusagen eine atombombe
ans bein gebunden waren er musste die
jetzt entschärfen das ist wirklich eine
parallele die zeigt die ganze und
ernsthaftigkeit nicht nur dieses mannes
sondern der gesamten veranstaltung wenn
indien bekannt gibt im jahre 2070
klimaneutral zu sein kann ich nur sagen
hoffentlich gibts indien dann noch wenn
die klimaneutral sein wollen und das ist
doch wir haben es doch selbst bei angela
merkel gesehen in den letzten jahren die
immer behauptet hat sich seine
klimakanzlerin was hat sie in wahrheit
fürs klima getan man könnte fast sagen
jeden fall jörg ist man könnte fast ein
blick auf das bild oder die bilder die
du gerade gesagt hat genannt hast
philipp haut der ju
klimagipfel haut der
milliardäre wie könnt ihr da so ein für
die laube und brasiliens und der größte
wären richtig und der größte doppelmoral
ist das ist ja boris johnson selbst der
gastgeber der ja mit seinem land 20 25
sogar klimaneutral werden will er sagt
es ist eine minute vor mitternacht der
aber jetzt wieder gesagt es wird die
kohlekraftwerke hoch warum weil die
gaspreise zu hoch sind weil er ein
problem der energiesicherheit in seinem
eigenen land hat habe es gibt eine große
debatte in großbritannien gerade über
die frage müssen wir eigentlich neue
erdölfelder
finden in der nordsee um das land
zukunftssicher zu haben um die
wirtschaft am laufen zu halten also how
der ju boris johnson wir sehen zwar im
eigenen land ehrlich gesagt ihr habt das
ja mal gemacht in der bild zeitung ihr
seid man in die in die flutgebiete
gefahren nach wochen und habe geguckt
was ist da eigentlich los und das viel
zu wenig los das thema ist schon wieder
ausgebucht aus dem öffentlichen
bewusstsein die menschen die dort immer
noch darum kämpfen dass sie irgendeinen
haus haben indem sie wenigstens wohnen
können auch wenn es nicht beheizt ist
dass sie strom und wasser haben die
fühlen sich doch zu recht allein
gelassen wie üblich wird das zugesagte
geld zu spät ausgezahlt in zu kleinen
beträgen ausgezahlt und unsere
diskussionen drehen sie schon wieder
völlig andere fragen um diese frage
jedenfalls nicht das ist ein ausgegrenzt
das gebiet als wäre es eine exklave
deutschlands da kämpfen die menschen ums
tägliche leben und niemand nimmt total
die sintflut gipfel ist ja auch einfach
nicht so sexy wie so ein klima ich meine
verpflichtet 400 privatjet die danach
nrw und rheinland pfalz liegen das wirkt
man sich ja
man da sein 30 jahren ja recht diesem
diese doppelmoral du kannst du wirklich
nur überzeugend wenn du selber mit einem
guten beispiel voran geht und wenn du da
halb im privatflieger dahin gehst da ist
die ganze debatte schon da hin weil dann
keiner mehr das glaubt was die leute
machen aber der gipfel zeigt ja einst
wir sind zu spät dran sind global zu
schlecht aufgestellt und dann versuchen
wir in deutschland als kleines land
überproportional zu sagen unseren
beitrag zu leisten und dann das führt
dann bei uns zu immensen debatten und zu
verwerfungen auch zur spaltung in der
gesellschaft und dann warten wir ein
bisschen das aus was global verpasst
wird ich habe da auch erschrocken wo ich
die nachricht gehört aber china 2070
grad eher sagen sogar na ja sagen ja
sogar greenpeace leute gut besser als
gar keine entscheidung aber 2070 ist
natürlich so weit weg da sitzen wir alle
nicht mehr hier und da wohl die immer
noch nicht der weiße hai mohring ob wir
nicht vielleicht doch hier sitzen wenn
jetzt das thema klima sie sind chef in
einer firma die
für den bau hersteller bzw überwachung
eigentlich vor anlagen um bauvorhaben im
zeitrahmen auch dann durchführen zu
können damit wenn was kaputt geht sieht
er rechtzeitig reingehen können um
verzögerungen vorzubeugen inwieweit ist
dieses thema was dort diskutiert wird
auf der klima controls eigentlich für
sie von relevanz von massiver relevanz
also im bau mit der gesamten
bauwirtschaft oder bewirtschaftung von
gebäuden tragen wir knapp 40 prozent der
gesamt tragen wir zur gesamtbilanz
massiv bei und ich glaube auch dass man
einfach mal so eine wertschöpfungskette
sich anschaut von der material
produktion bis zur tatsächlichen
errichtung eines hauses und dann auch
wiederum das was jetzt auf uns zukommt
mit entweder grün grüner energie oder
auch noch eher altertümlicher das ist
etwas was man massiv unterschätzt und
ich glaube auch dass innerhalb der
jeweiligen nation und auch der
wirtschaften sehr sehr viele ideen
schlummern niemand das verbessern kann
wie man auf kurzen wege da auch mit bio
diesel was es auch mal sein mag
tatsächlich mehr fortschritt erreichen
kann ich persönlich halte nichts von
diesen supranationalen lösungen weil das
führt zu keiner lösung in den meisten
fällen wir brauchen dann entschlacken
das einfach auf kleiner ebene auf dem
kurzen dienstweg was verändert werden
kann so dass ich dann halt die geschenke
oder irgendjemand anders zum
alternativen kraftstoff entschärft ihnen
mehr als unternehmerin ein verbot oder
ein gebot
einfach nur freiheit also tatsächlich
rahmenbedingungen die alle die einen
erlauben vielleicht auch mal mit
steuervorteilen einfach investitionen zu
tätigen
da bin ich sehr sehr nahe bei der fdp
dass man sich auch anschaut okay wie
kann man sich tatsächlich jetzt mit
innovationen auch welt auf der ganzen
auf dem in der weltpolitik anders
aufstellen das thema solar 1 1 ein
patent und eine kreation die in
deutschland hervorgerufen hat womit
mittlerweile extrem viel potenzial
weltweit gehoben wird und wir haben es
verpasst davon ökonomischen
partizipieren ich glaube wir müssen uns
einfach wieder mal eine gedanken
gewöhnen politik ist von den von der
aktualität der probleme und fand deren
wucht eigentlich immer überfordert sie
kommt immer zu spät sie handelt immer
erst dann wenn die probleme unabweisbar
sind und in diesem fall klimaschutz ist
es da noch nachweisbar wenn nichts mehr
zu retten ist oder nicht mehr viel zu
retten ist vielleicht würde sich das
ändern wenn in den usa so viel
atomwaffen lager überschwemmt würden
oder die klima demonstranten würden
nicht mehr friedlich sein sondern
anfangen die regierungszentralen zu
verkloppen dann würde sich vielleicht
irgendwas ändern aber ich habe meine
hoffnung setzt sich nur in
die kreativität von ingenieuren und
unternehmen muss ich sagen ich glaube
sowieso nicht dran dass der staat mit
einem irrsinnigen milliardensummen etwas
bewegt das ist üblicherweise die
deutsche debatte haben wir den genug
geld um das alles zu finanzieren
man muss nur den unternehmern und den
den den ingenieuren und kreativen die
möglichkeit geben ihre eigenen
möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen und das
stimme ich mit ihnen völlig überein die
fdp hat vorgeschlagen eine
sonderabschreibung von zwei jahren dann
hat man das investment völlig von der
steuer wieder reingeholt
sonderabschreibung auf alles was im
klimaschutz dienst ist viel sinnvoller
als irgendwie ein riesen öffentliches
wörterbuch genau